I just want some water in a glass and
some lemon okay
I'll be right back okay
what time tacos some tacos mm-hmm okay
got it
Kris Jenner is keeping up all right
keeping up with Kylie's post surgery
demands rave right here in a sneak peek
at Keeping Up with the Kardashians the
famous momager is right by her little
girl's side
following her LASIK eye surgery Kylie's
just coming home from her LASIK surgery
and she's a bit out of it I just want to
make sure she's okay
because the healthiest thing she can do
right now is get some rest yeah and she
gives her a little gold bell that she
says she can ring anytime she needs
something I brought you this little bell
you can if you just go then I'm going to
come okay okay okay all right
guys cardinal rule of life never ever
ever give anyone a bell hello Eve right
here I mean you can see where this is
going right mommy mommy mommy yeah it's
Bell City her first request I just want
some water in a glass some lemon okay
I'll be right back thank you then the 22
year old asks her mama for this
okay what's up really want some tacos
some tacos mm-hmm okay got it
wait but tacos actually do sound really
good mom how do you guys live without
Lowry salt oh here it is
and that Bell you guys uh mom is Chris
made those tacos and even fed them to
Kylie what are you doing standing up
Kylie
back up back up let me put this down
let's use this as a little tablecloth
okay when you smell the taco open your
mouth I smell it so weird
well she messed with Kylie then fed them
to her okay take a big bite I know I'm
sorry okay jokes over
here's it I know he did hook up and when
the food is good you guys you dance
[Music]
Kylie is just proof that even if you're
a grown-ass adults billionaire sometimes
a girl just needs her mama of course in
2019 Kylie was named Forbes youngest
self-made billionaire at the time the
beauty mogul and Forbes received a lot
of flak some people just couldn't get
behind the title self-made noting that
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
had the help of her famous family to
build her fortune not like that was
handed to her she figured that all out I
mean we all have at the time Kylie
sister Kim and her mama defended her
title to ET she works really hard she
made her own money for over a decade she
put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
and earlier this month
Kylie secured the title again for the
second year in a row and Forbes defended
the use of self-made writing quote she
didn't inherit her business she built it
[Music]